[Applause]
okay we're here on CNN with the
co-author of the book The canceling of
the American line Greg lukanov CNN
senior political analy and anchor John
Aon and special correspondent for PS
news hour Jane Ferguson okay here are
the questions that the people of America
want to know of our CNN panel you're
often on a CNN panel yes I am okay so
this is just new to you not new to you
what does the panel think of choosing
Taylor Swift As Time Magazine person of
the year 100% for it she totally
deserves it I'm not
kidding uh no I mean yeah who can argue
her on the cat though the cat should get
credit she's I mean it's a it's a
phenomenal year I mean we have not seen
a year like that in Show Business maybe
ever um what are the panel's thoughts on
Hunter Biden being
indicted I
look
it just it just shows that the Equal
justice under law exists the president's
son you know is going to get busted for
evading taxes and you know he did in a
lot of moment of grief and that doesn't
really matter because he got to obey the
law no matter whose son you are no
matter who it does
really no two tier
Jus it does really point up that one
side does consider the law a little more
seriously than the other and the fact
that they kind of compare it to Trump
like Hunter Biden is not our hero okay
you
know okay uh what kind of interference
can we expect from Russia as the 2024
election heats up none needed
well
but but actually there there's a story
that just came out yesterday in the UK
that us was involved as well that Russia
is doing cyber hacking specifically with
the goal of not only disrupting their
election but eroding faith in democracy
itself and I think that's the larger
Stakes then we've seen this on on Tik
Tok a lot of the things that go viral
you've discussed that um you know and
now you know you see she you know Trump
losing no opportunity to pray she in
every campaign speech you know the guy
just Donald Trump loves dictators but I
think that dramatically increases the
chance of interference only because
people are going to want those
autocratic alternatives are going to
want to degrade democracy and put us on
a path towards decline but are we
flattering ourselves and thinking that
that's what they need to do as opposed
to sit back and watch I mean like people
you know by there was there was of
course the misinformation campaign and
thoughts on Twitter making us all you
know get outraged and row and fight but
it feels like that's taken on an organic
life of its own now and like perhaps
we're flattering ourselves by saying it
must be in interference I mean we've
seen this we see this in other parts of
the world you know whenever people you
know rise up against uh against uh you
know their leaders and everyone says
it's a conspiracy I mean by all means
Russia will and would love to interfere
I kind of wonder if like these days they
really need to I mean this election is
not looking too tight yeah in in
cancelling we talk a lot about what
experts have done to undermine their own
credibility unfortunately in recent
years and that's also a big thing that
Russia's trying to do as well and
unfortunately they're it's like you know
they're complimenting each other in the
worst possible way sure okay what did
the panel think of thees grandis Swami's
performance at the debate this
week
I mean I had to watch that yeah did you
watch I
did it's not on the test
right uh if he didn't see it it in one
answer he managed to connect every
conspiracy theory from the 21st century
that's from from 9 911 well except it
was clearly a dog whistle to folks on
the far right to sort of connect 911 say
January 6 was an inside job to talk
about the great replacement Theory and
and saying it was at the Democratic
party platform uh and and to say and to
repeat 2020 election lies which are now
a litmus test within the party that
symbolizes everything wrong in our
politics it's totally disgusting it's
disqualifying it's pathetic and it's
pandering he's
done pisses me off but also I think it
also though uh really speaks to a level
of desperation I mean you have to you
have to be pretty scared to start
connecting more and more and more
conspiracy theories together I mean
there's got to be like a limit to where
you know once you've had too many then
you really look like you're losing work
in Pizza gate right but also
just well he did with the Chris Christie
joke oh did he really well he worked in
Pizza uh or something didn't he say
something I mean he made he made a a a
fat joke but Chris Christie I just want
to I tried to like this guy I had him on
my podcast he had him on the show he's a
personable guy but I just got to say you
youth shows itself I mean he kept saying
the debates I watched he kept saying
it's time for a new generation which
they all say when the young guy comes
along and this just showed it's not be
this generation not that guy what not
that guy well not that guy because it
just just showed you know come back what
my advice then would stop just stop with
go go away come back he's 38 years old
come back in 10 or 20 years and say oh
yeah you know what I can't believe I did
what I did when I was 38 cuz we can all
relate to
that and then like actually run for
office not just straight for president
because you want to get famous because
you know your idsy is showing I mean it
and also just seems so performative like
I get it what he's thinking is the
Republican Party likes dicks it
does but you know with Trump it's
authentic now you're kind of
complimenting him he's not really a dick
he's not I think he's playing one that
that's almost worse that's exactly it is
worse it's almost worse Trump can't help
being a
dick this guy is playing
one also I must say tell you a number of
indianamerican Indian Americans I know
who are friends of mine have said bill
please tell America he does not
represent us you know that's like that's
a bad guy to go out first but there's
Nikki Haley Nikki Haley who you know
like do I agree with everything n no but
could I easily live under Nikki Haley's
America yes and I might even enjoy it I
don't know I mean look this is
all what H what's going to happen in the
next two months between Iowa and New
Hampshire is going to be enormously I
mean this is a time for choosing
Republicans have one last chance to not
renominate someone who tried to overturn
our
democracy yeah okay um James are the
right Dublin is your hometown uh well
New York City um I come I come from
Northern Ireland just north of the
Border oh Northern Ireland it's complex
yes oh I know uh are the riots in Dublin
a sign that extremist politics are
gaining a foothold in Ireland okay so
explain what I read it but you have to
explain it's pretty wild so Ireland I
mean I had to reread the story several
times about musk wasn't it no it was it
was really kind of it's It's a fomenting
of a sort of uh very very tiny minority
that's very loud and very violent um
that that it basically it's you know
anti-immigration and it's it's all the
usual populist kind of conversations I
think what stirred them up wasn't it
something on Twitter I refuse to call it
x a lot of
it a lot of it come a lot of it comes
down to like rumors and misinformation
and and it but it's grounded and so
Twitter's big big part of that there in
this case case but but Twitter's better
isn't it I feel like it's so much easier
to go uh Twitter I refuse to call it X
then go X formally Twitter yeah X used
to be a drug you know like that's what
that's what people used to you know but
um and I'm also going to call Kanye
Kanye I'm not going to
go people but the but the Irish thing
though I mean honestly like the the
thing that concerns me is that whenever
you start having a pretty sort of
violent extremely right-wing uh riot in
Ireland I mean this is just this is
unprecedented we've had them here but
yeah but I mean never in Ireland like I
mean Ireland is it is so antithetical to
everything you know we know about
Ireland was the first country to by
popular vote legalize gay marriage you
know I mean Ireland is is one of the
most late in the game though a lot has
changed when when what year was that
that was 15 years ago 10 years ago
that's kind of late in the game all
right raise a glass to Shane mcau by the
way speaking of Ireland
yeah what but I will say the pugs died
the attempt to ban hate speech in
Ireland that got passed recently I we
see the same thing going in going on in
France and they can't seem to understand
that they passed these anti-Semitism
laws in the 90s and somehow
anti-Semitism got worse and it's because
you told all the anti-semites that they
can only talk to other anti-semites what
did you expect to happen and this is
actually the same thing on college
campuses when students are not talking
to one another they're not like having
civil discourse opinions don't go away
because you B someone saying them we
need to get like especially students on
campus make them sit down and talk make
them debate and make them like say this
to each other's this is one of the most
important things that your show's doing
right now which is defining liberal
values and saying we need to stand up
against liberalism on the left as well
as the right and there's a group of
Common Sense Democrats liberal Patriots
radical centrists that need to start
taking the conversation back all right
well said thank you everybody we'll see
you next week for our in
finale